hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to minecraft it's been
a while
which was just enough time for my crops
to grow
because i'm a good farmer i'm a good
farmer
and i'm about to murder my cows like a
good farmer
anyway oh satisfying oh it's satisfying
oh the satisfaction oh nice
that was good why are you wrong
you're clearly not right why are you
wrong why are these wrong
did i fall i fell probably where's my
hoe
i thought i was a good farmer apparently
not i don't even have a hoe
oh this is full one problem at a time
take care of that and take care of this
and then
join us now i have to replant it
is there like a mod that replants things
automatically
this is tedious i'm not even eating it
for my cows
to make more cows for the miracle of
life
boring okay hey
wow we did it okay now i gotta go get my
i need another box uh i still appreciate
the genius of how i designed this
but man it's it's a little tedious
but i love it because i'm so smart and i
built it intelligently
okay uh doink uh
doink uh enchanted book
what do i do with an enchanted book um
whatever
doesn't matter to me if i don't know it
it's not important
all right satisfying
all right cool that was a lot of
it's not paper what is it what is it
it's not paper
what is it what is it sugar cane a lot
of sugar cane
and this should be enough to send me
forth on making a whole bunch
more i don't have leather but i can make
paper
paper paper paper bam
oh i love that i love that now let's go
make some more cows
hey moo moose hey moo-moos
hey boo-boos hey moo-moos wow oh my
goodness
has a lot of moose everybody fat
everybody eating all right
[Music]
axe time
[Music]
hang on give me oh
pickaxe i don't want to sort them
because it might get the
the little oh no what if i jump yeah
spank lump yum yum this
is working oh
i really like how it lights them on fire
all right
hey little ones come here do you need
food
can i feed you grow their heads are
growing their heads are huge
is this working i don't know if that
worked stop eating all my stuff
that'll be fine that'll be totally fine
anyway i got
oh 27 leather
that's pretty good where's the book book
27 books which means i have no wood
which means finally i can make
drum roll please
nine bookshelves i thought i would have
more
but i'll take nine nine's good
nine is great look at all this knowledge
look at all that knowledge flowing in
that beautiful beautiful knowledge okay
so what are we up to now
what what can we do
level four level requirement 30. wait
what i have to be 30 but i'm spending on
my
but that's oh that's a lot wait i don't
have
that what shut up you're dumb and i hate
you what
why are you so stupid what are you doing
to me saddle i'm gonna
make a horse mine horse come here
ah it's night i'm gonna go sleep i'll
think about this you
i'm coming for you tomorrow now
now it's time today is the day
what if you like woke up in the morning
you just heard someone screaming in a
distance
it's today now is the time that i will
have you
hey horse come here wow it's an
unisonous horse hello
take some of this oh you like carrots
i have some of those i have two of those
actually
and with these carrots you shall be mine
forever
hey hey girl carrot hey
saddle saddle herod
come on come on don't be that way
hey hey he doesn't like me maybe if i
take a hay bale
you guys mind if i steal one of these
you like a hay bale
like a bale of hay oh
hey bail you ate the hay bale what more
do you want
this is unacceptable this is clearly
unacceptable i do not accept this
my lights are all wrong what is with
this no no no wha
what is going on where's my lights
that's not the right color this is
terrible
oh there they go that's nice that'll do
okay now back to me hating this horse do
i have enough
wheat for it yeah sure i i don't know if
this is helping it
ate the hay bale i mean i could just
steal the hay bales that he had before
all right you glutton okay it's eating
them
what are you doing how many do you need
how many do you need how many do you
need
how many do you need i am riding you
whoa
hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
messy whoa whoa nelly what if i
ride you then feed you a carrot to calm
you down
carrot carrot
it's really it's a wily one ah
what have i done hello
oh
[Music]
wow i love this
i didn't even know that this was a thing
that i was gonna do today but now i'm
happy that i
woke up because this is amazing hey okay
wait i gotta build you a
a paddock i'm using the correct
translation of paddock right
this time i didn't use it correctly
before as i thought and
you know i noticed suspiciously that you
didn't make it seem that i was correct
instead you proved me wrong
you're supposed to be looking out for me
i'll this would be a paddock with a door
sure to be the greatest paddock ever
nope
hey well i'm going to call you swoopy
after the
horses met a very unfortunate fate
schwambles get in there swampy you know
i'm going you don't like your paddock
what's wrong with your panic you don't
like the paddock that i explicitly built
for you
schwoompi the schwumster you telling me
the schwoomster don't like the paddock
well too bad schwomby
now you get locked in forever
[Laughter]
you want a hay bill there you go
and it's reinforced the fence sticks
right to it
you got enough space oh my god we have
so much steak
that's cooked steak too because my sword
lit it on fire therefore the steak was
cooked
i love that that is amazing all right
we're gonna make a new
diamond pickaxe i had one but now i have
two
this is gonna be the big the big kahuni
i just feel like you didn't give me the
good stuff i feel as though you
were supposed to give me the good stuff
and yet you are not currently giving me
any of the good stuff that i was
promised you
seem to have a hesitation to providing
me with the stuff
that you know is good and i don't think
i appreciate that
it's insulting to me and um frankly it's
insulting to
you because if you're not willing to
provide me with the good stuff then
i'll have to take the good stuff from
you and you will not
enjoy the process i will play i will i
will not take pleasure in the process
either but i will do what it takes to
ensure that the supply of good stuff is
provided as promised
so why don't we go over this again
and you give me the good
that's not the good stuff i need more
experience
well guess who's gonna go on a midnight
killing spree
this guy which means that i need a new
sword
a diamond sword yes
now can you give me some good stuff on
this
please sweeping edge two
that's barely any better than
oh hey hi time to murder lexi and hit
the
sweet epic combat time lapse i'm on fire
trumpy we ride to victory
charge can i run him over off
go away get ah my horse no you're not
gonna kill swoopy
oh don't kill you don't kill you don't
kill you
let's go we're running away oh my god
swoopy don't die
don't die oh my god don't die don't dice
whoopee oh my god cut the music lixie
and cut the music oh my god oh my god oh
my god
all right swoopy i need to make you
armor
uh didn't know about that one
um i don't see any recipes
what are you doing away from my crops
okay schwoompi you uh rest up
i don't know how to make you armor uh so
i'll figure it out later
dead lixian cue up the combat music
again
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay great that was great great stuff
hey schwoompulse you're not eating these
are you you're you're not are you you're
not you're definitely not it should be
enough to get these
cows going go go go go
go go go go go
i get all of you i guess i shouldn't
have killed so many all right cool
being a farmer's tough protect my crops
level up eh you know it sucks because
also when i as soon as i enchant
something i'm going to lose my levels
oh there's got to be a better way this
gives like no experience i get better
experience from farming
coal you know what i do get better
experience from farming coal
why aren't i doing that why aren't i
just farm no no
no go away no not now not in you don't
do that in my base
you don't get to do that
all right well that was a good night of
killing things
i'm gonna steal their wheat
i didn't notice the thing hey you guys
want some more wheat
no more wheat to be had all right fine
then be that way okay honestly i could
have gotten more experience by just
mining so actually you know i i
might just do that wha what what
what are you what are you judging me are
you
judging my horse what are you judging me
oh i'm sorry are you judging me oh yeah
walk away oh not confronted oh
fell in a hole trying to hide from me oh
you were judging me and now you're
running away oh you think you're
better than me oh yeah you squaring up
on me
huh yeah you better walk away don't go
near my horse
don't you sigh at me i won't destroy
your entire oh
are you coming back oh you coming back
oh you want to fight
huh big nose yeah yeah you don't want
any of this oh don't look down at me
oh don't look down at me oh i'm looking
down at you and shaking my head
no no no no oh oh yeah you better walk
away
you better walk away i'm gonna go dig
some stuff
okay i went that way i went that way
time to go this way
oh my goodness oh my gosh
oh
[Applause]
oh
this is the path this is the way i
should have known
and apparently if i press f it holsters
that
this is the way
see i do get more experience from just
cold and killing monsters
i get so much experience look at all
this
okay all right cool good man
love this game so
nice
it is nice this is the way oh this is
the way
i've been shown the way this is the way
oh my goodness this oh my
goodness this path this path
oh this pass oh the path oh the path
oh the path that has been laid before me
oh my goodness i have seen
the way and it is thus i don't know why
i feel a compulsion to fill in the holes
that i dig
out that's i i just it feels right
all right where have we here
yes i'm so close to level 30. but also
i've got the problem of it as soon as i
use it up to go
get that enchantment i won't be level 30
anymore and therefore i won't be able to
do anything else
because i think it still costs only
three levels but i need to be
30 to get it which is a problem
and i keep going what is that
what what is that what is netherrack
wha what wait wait stop what huh
what's happening why why
why oh what the hell
why ah i'm stuck help help i'm a
helpless baby
help help help help help
help help how oh
it's one of these things oh
and they give you the obsidian wow
aqua affinity huh does that mean i can
swim better
breathe underwater i think it's better
they just got a portal right here and
the necessary supplies with which to
activate it
that's very handy why can't i make flint
and steel i don't have steel
well i don't know if i want to go to the
nether right now but it's right in front
of me i literally can't avoid it
i don't have any wood though so i
literally can't make it okay that would
be that would be cool
that would be totally rad if i could do
anything with that
but i can't so i won't but it exists
so that's neat
what the hecking hell
was that
excuse me
what is that oh
hi oh okay
oh well that was terrible
okay oh wow well you know
no this is a no no this is oh nothing
you fight it out you fight it out
you guys have fun in there you go oh why
almost died okay hey i found diamond
over here
i am doing
great great great
great great stuff great stuff everybody
really good stuff solid work all the way
through
couldn't have done with this without any
of you
okay all right that's enough for now i
didn't quite get
33 like i had been attempting to but
that's all right because
i've got a lot of iron and some gold and
i should be able to smelt them
into the necessary materials such that i
can get
enough experience mission successful
we got experience we got supplies and we
got
more diamonds who'd have thought
almost too easy what the heck
how what what what is with your head
what what is
hey what the hell your hat is so scary
you're hey what are you oh my god wow
wow
your hat i don't like it what is wrong
with you
wow yo your hat
is terrifying what is with your hat
oh what
the hell what the hell what is the
symbol in the
right mean what does that mean what
ominous bear yeah ominous
yeah no kidding ominous what are you
doing up here
what happened what happened i don't
know oh wow i had a lot of experience
waiting for me there
33 hey 33 though okay that's good
i have that and i got a lot of diamond
which is also good
i'm just a little confused as to
everything else that was going on
i'm gonna shake that off gonna feed my
cows
act like nothing happened go go go
cows go you be i put the banner down
and what no i no i don't no give me the
oh my god
can i get that can i what can i have the
ban
i don't know i i want the banner no i
want the
bit hot oh my god everyone come over
here
then forget about it and i'm gonna take
the banner
okay you know uh it's not a bad idea to
have the banner there but
uh i i'd rather yeah there we go yeah
okay
sure uh
i'm going to make iron armor
ah because i deserve it and because i'm
amazing
but i'm not gonna make the iron helmet
because i have the amazing
gold helmet that gives me aqua affinity
and i know it's made of gold that
probably means it's very weak
but that's pretty cool protection
how about just protection too that's
good enough
i don't need unbreaking it's diamond it
never breaks
protection protect me that's pretty good
blast protection ah perfection this is
the good stuff
protection oh this is the good stuff oh
my goodness look at this good
stuff oh my goodness
oh oh yeah
the armor's dead that one half's got oh
but i
the aqua affinity is so good i don't
know
is it good i don't know
maybe a diamond helmet why not just to
complete the set because it bugs me
all right this put the lapuzi and
projectile projection oh
four and aqua affinity i still got
yes yes
i am fully armored nothing can st
ah nothing can stand in my way anymore
i'm a one-man army standing alone
i need no one on my side just me and
schwoobles by my side forever alone
but me on my own but me with my friends
and all those who support me i am a
champion i'm going to sleep
all right so that's great i did amazing
things today
i am the greatest minecraft player to
ever live
and i am very comfortable with making
that claim and my cows are now
permanently protected
with the uh edition of this banner i
have saved the world
thank you everybody so much for watching
uh in the next episode
i'm gonna try to do redstone
that's gonna go well let me know how i'm
doing in the comments below and as
always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
[Music]
you